>> SECRETARY JANET YELLEN,
WELCOME TO THE PROGRAM.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
INVITATION.
>> WE WILL GET TO YOUR MEETING
AND TRIP AND SPEECH IN AFRICA
IN A MOMENT, BUT FIRST I WANT
TO ASK YOU ABOUT SOMETHING ELSE
REALLY TOP OF YOUR MIND.
THAT IS THE DEBT CEILING.
YOU INFORMED CONGRESS THAT THE
DEBT CEILING HAS BEEN REACHED
AND THAT YOU HAVE TO EMPLOY
EXTRAORDINARY MEASURES TO KEEP
THE WHOLE THING GOING.
HOW LONG CAN YOU DO THAT FOR?
WHAT KIND OF EXTRAORDINARY
MEASURES?
>> WELL, EXTRAORDINARY MEASURES
INVOLVE THINGS LIKE THE CIVIL
SERVICE TRUST FUND AND
INVESTMENTS THAT WE MAKE IN
GOVERNMENT SECURITIES FOR
EMPLOYEES IN GOVERNMENT FUNDED
PROGRAMS.
AND I INDICATED IN MY LETTER TO
CONGRESS THAT WE FEEL CONFIDENT
THEY CAN LAST UNTIL EARLY JUNE,
BUT BEYOND THAT THERE IS NO
GUARANTEE.
THE ACTUAL DATE THAT WE WILL NO
LONGER BE ABLE TO USE THESE
MEASURES IS QUITE UNCERTAIN.
IT COULD CONCEIVABLY COME AS
EARLY AS EARLY JUNE.
>> OKAY, SO I WANT TO JUST
QUOTE THAT LETTER THAT YOU ARE
REFERRING TO A LITTLE BIT.
FAILURE TO MEET THE GOVERNMENTS
OBLIGATIONS WOULD CAUSE
IRREPARABLE HARM TO THE UNITED
STATES ECONOMY, THE LIVELIHOODS
OF ALL AMERICANS, AND GLOBAL
FINANCIAL STABILITY.
SO IN BRIEF, WHAT KIND OF
IRREPARABLE HARM, AND
PARTICULARLY FOR AMERICAN
HOUSEHOLDS, HOW WOULD AVERAGE
AMERICAN HOUSEHOLD EXPERIENCE
THIS?
>> THE UNITED STATES IS A
COUNTRY THAT SINCE 1789 HAS
ALWAYS PAID ALL OF ITS BILLS.
THE KNOWLEDGE THAT THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT CAN BE TRUSTED AND
COUNTED ON TO DO THAT UNDER
LIES THE FOUNDATIONS OF THE
ENTIRE GLOBAL FINANCIAL SYSTEM
REALLY.
U.S. TREASURY SECURITIES ARE
THE SAFEST INVESTMENT ON THE
PLANET, AND WE WOULD CERTAINLY
EXPERIENCE AT A MINIMUM EIGHT
DOWNGRADING OF OUR DEBT.
IF THAT HAPPENED, OUR BORROWING
COSTS WOULD INCREASED AND EVERY
AMERICAN WOULD SEE THAT THEY'RE
BORROWING COSTS WOULD INCREASE
AS WELL.
ON TOP OF THAT, A FAILURE TO
MAKE PAYMENTS THAT ARE DUE,
WHETHER IT IS TO BOND HOLDERS
OR TO SOCIAL SECURITY
RECIPIENTS, OR TO OUR MILITARY,
WE WOULD UNDOUBTEDLY COST
RECESSION IN THE U.S. ECONOMY.
IT COULD CAUSE A GLOBAL
FINANCIAL CRISIS.
IT WOULD CERTAINLY UNDERMINE
THE ROLE OF THE DOLLAR AS
RESERVE CURRENCY THAT IS USED
IN TRANSACTIONS ALL OVER THE
WORLD.
AMERICANS, MANY PEOPLE WOULD
LOSE THEIR JOBS, AND CERTAINLY,
THEIR BORROWING COSTS WOULD
RISE.
>> GOSH, I MEAN TO ME, I'M A
LATE PERSON WHEN IT COMES TO
THE ECONOMY, BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE
AN UNMITIGATED DISASTER.
YOU BELIEVE, YOU JUST TOLD ME,
THAT YOU BELIEVE SOME
RESOLUTION CAN BE FOUND.
THE SENATE REPUBLICAN LEADER
MITCH MCCONNELL ALSO BELIEVES
THAT SOME RESOLUTION CAN BE
FOUND.
BUT, YOU DO HAVE WHAT SOME HAVE
TURNED THE FLAME THROWERS ON
THE EXTREME WING OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, PARTICULARLY
IN THE HOUSE, AND THEY ARE
STICKING QUITE FIRMLY TO WHAT
THEY SAY THEY HAVE PROMISED
THAT THE PEOPLE.
THEY CLAIM THEY HAVE A MANDATE
TO GET CONTROL OF RECKLESS
SPENDING.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT IS WHAT IS
HAPPENING HERE?
THAT THERE IS RECKLESS SPENDING?
THAT UNLESS YOU GET IT UNDER
CONTROL SOMEHOW, THIS DISASTER
YOU JUST OUTLINED WILL UNFOLD?
>> THE DEBT CEILING IT'S ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT WE CAN PAY OUR
BILLS.
WE'VE ALREADY INCURRED FOR
SPENDING THAT HAS BEEN
AUTHORIZED BY CONGRESS.
SO IT'S NOT ABOUT SEEKING THE
RIGHT TO ENGAGE IN ADDITIONAL
SPENDING.
IT IS SIMPLY ABOUT PAYING BILLS
CONGRESS HAS ALREADY
AUTHORIZED.
CONGRESS IS --
HAS, IN THE PAST, ALWAYS ACTED
TO RAISE THE DEBT CEILING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN PAY OUR
BILLS.
THIS IS SOMETHING WE CAN'T
NEGOTIATE OVER OR BARGAIN ABOUT.
AMERICA HAS TO BE A RELIABLE
BORROWER THAT PAYS ALL THE
BILLS THAT ARE DUE ON TIME.
CONGRESS NEEDS TO FIND A WAY TO
GET THIS DONE, AND IT ALWAYS
HAS IN THE BEST.
>> INDEED, IT ALWAYS HAS IN THE
PAST.
YOU MENTIONED THE HORRIBLE WORD
RECESSION, IT WOULD ENSURE
THERE IS A RECESSION IF YOU
FAILED TO PAY THOSE BILLS.
AND IT HAPPENS RIGHT IN THE
MIDDLE OF A GLOBAL ISSUE, A
GLOBAL SORT OF RECESSIONARY
SORT OF STATUS.
YOU HAVE JUST BEEN MEETING IN
SWITZERLAND, NOT DAVOS, WITH
THE CHINESE VICE PREMIER.
WHAT SIGNIFICANCE DID YOU
ACHIEVE WITH YOUR TALKS?
>> FIRST OF ALL, IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT THE WORLD'S TWO LARGEST
ECONOMIES BE IN REGULAR
COMMUNICATION ABOUT THEIR OWN
MACROECONOMIC POLICIES, THE
PROGRESS OF THEIR ECONOMY'S,
AND THE PROBLEMS THAT THE
GLOBAL ECONOMY AND FINANCIAL
SYSTEM FACE.
THIS WAS OUR FIRST IN-PERSON
MEETING.
PRESIDENT BIDEN MET WITH
PRESIDENT XI AND IT WAS AGREED
THAT THESE ARE MATTERS THAT WE
NEED TO DISCUSS ON A REGULAR
BASIS.
PEOPLE AT ALL LEVELS OF OUR
GOVERNMENT.
SO WE TALKED ABOUT THESE THINGS.
IN ADDITION, THE WORLD'S TWO
MOST IMPORTANT ECONOMIES HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO COOPERATE ON
ISSUES THAT ARE OF GLOBAL
SIGNIFICANCE.
I'M THINKING HERE OF CLIMATE
CHANGE, PREPARING FOR FUTURE
PANDEMICS, RUSSIA'S BRUTAL AND
UNPROVOKED WAR AGAINST UKRAINE,
HAS LED TO AN INCREASE IN
HUNGER, FOOD INSECURITY, ALL
AROUND THE GLOBE.
WE NEED TO DISCUSS HOW TO
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM, THE
PROBLEM A VERY HIGH ENERGY
PRICES, AND IN MANY CASES AND
SUSTAINABLE DEBT FOR LOW INCOME
COUNTRIES THAT ARE COMING OUT
OF THE PANDEMIC.
THEY NOW FACE VERY WEAK GLOBAL
CONDITIONS AND SEE DEPRECIATING
CURRENCIES.
SO THESE ARE THINGS WE NEED TO
COOPERATE ON.
WE HAVE SHARED INTERESTS.
WE DISCUSSED OUR COOPERATION
AND THE NEED TO WORK TOGETHER
TO ADDRESS GLOBAL CHALLENGES.
VERY BRIEFLY, YOU SAY WE NEED
TO, WE DISCUSSED.
DO YOU SEE LIGHT AT THE END OF
THIS TUNNEL?
WILL YOU?
TODAY SEEM WILLING?
>> YES, THEY DO SEEM WILLING.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND PRESIDENT
XI AGREED ON IN THEIR MEETING.
THEY ASKED THEIR COLLEAGUES AND
STAFF TO FOLLOW UP.
I SEE DEFINITE GOOD PROSPECTS
FOR COOPERATION ON THESE
MATTERS.
>> LET ME ASK YOU THEN ABOUT
YOUR TRIP TO AFRICA.
WE ARE TALKING TO YOU FROM
SENEGAL.
YOU GAVE A BIG SPEECH AND YOU
SAID THAT AMERICA IS IN
PARTNERSHIP AND WANTS TO BE IN
AFRICA, NOT TRANSACTIONAL, NOT
FOR THE SHORT HAUL, BUT THE
LONG HAUL.
IN THAT SPEECH, YOU SAID A FEW
THINGS, ONE OF THEM IS
COUNTRIES NEED TO BE WEARY OF
SHINY DEALS THAT MAY BE OPAQUE
AND ULTIMATELY FAILED TO
ACTUALLY BENEFIT THE PEOPLE
THEY WERE PURPORTEDLY DESIGNED
TO HELP IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THIS CAN LEAVE COUNTRIES WITH A
LEGACY OF THAT, DIVERGENT
RESOURCES, AND ENVIRONMENTAL
DESTRUCTION.
I WONDER BECAUSE THAT SOUNDS
VERY MUCH LIKE A MESSAGE TO
AFRICAN NATIONS ABOUT THE
INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF TRADE THEY
DO WITH CHINA, THE INCREDIBLE
AMOUNT OF INVESTMENT THE CHINA
HAS DONE FAR OUTSTRIPPING WHAT
UNITED STATES HAS DONE, AT
LEAST FOR THE LAST TEN PLUS
YEARS.
IS THAT WHAT YOU ARE TRYING TO
TELL AFRICAN COUNTRIES?
>> IT'S TRUE THAT AFRICA HAS
BORROWED A LOT FROM CHINA FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS, AND
THAT THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF DEBT
INCURRED IN THAT PROCESS.
A PROBLEM WITH THAT IS THAT, IN
SOME CASES, THE PROJECTS
INVOLVED ENVIRONMENTAL
DESTRUCTION OR LEFT THE
COUNTRIES WITH UNSUSTAINABLE
DEBT BURDENS?
AND NOW WITH A WEAK GLOBAL
ECONOMY AND HIGH DEBT, MANY
COUNTRIES IN AFRICAN LOW INCOME
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD ARE
DEALING WITH DEBT BURDENS THAT
THEY SIMPLY CAN'T MANAGE.
YOU KNOW, THE UNITED STATES
WANTS TO BE THERE.
MY TRIP, AS YOU SAID, IS ABOUT
MANY YEARS TO COME.
WE SEE WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
AFRICA.
AFRICA IS REALLY CRUCIAL TO THE
LONGER TERM GLOBAL OUTLOOK.
THIS IS A CONTINENT THAT'S
POPULATION IS GROWING VERY
RAPIDLY.
IT'S A VERY YOUNG POPULATION.
IT HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
CONTRIBUTE TO GROWTH THROUGHOUT
THE GLOBAL ECONOMY.
NOT MANAGED PROPERLY, IT COULD
BE A SOURCE OF PROBLEMS.
YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
INVESTMENTS ARE HIGH QUALITY.
THAT THEY LEAD TO, IN THE CASE
OF ENERGY, THAT THEY ARE
SUSTAINABLE INVESTMENTS.
IN THE CASE OF AGRICULTURE, WE
SEE COUNTRIES THAT NEED MORE
RESILIENCE --
RESILIENT AGRICULTURAL SYSTEMS,
ESPECIALLY WITH CLIMATE CHANGE
TAKING A TOLL ON MANY COUNTRIES
IN AFRICA OVER THE MEDIUM TERM.
WE SEE HUGE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
AMERICAN BUSINESS HERE.
SO ENCOURAGING TRADE AND
INVESTMENT BETWEEN THE UNITED
STATES AND AFRICA IS SOMETHING
THAT IS A WIN WIN BOTH FOR THE
UNITED STATES AND ALSO FOR
AFRICA.
WE WANT TO BE THERE AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE NEED TO DO
TO FACILITATE THIS GROWTH AND
TRADE.